a show of military might for the rest of
the continent to see Venezuela's again
deployed its army along the border with
Colombia this week for war games
increasing tensions between the two
troubled nations but those studying -
well and military say this is mostly
posturing for political effect from an
increasingly unprofessional force
well the Venezuelan military is quite a
politicized force right you are promoted
because of loyalty to the government and
it's military professionalism has
suffered drastically the patronage
element is visible in the fact that they
have 2,000 generals that is more than
all the countries of NATO combined your
him clan Schmidt has been researching
Venezuela's armed forces in their
relationship with their ally Russia he
says that when commodity prices were
high the oil-rich country bought some
impressive pieces of equipment such as
two dozen state-of-the-art Sukhoi Jets
but received little training on how to
use them no if we look at the Venezuelan
Navy in the 1990s it used to be a
reasonably sized force with somewhat
advanced equipment and now we know that
of six frigates three have sunk at the
pier and the other three might be more
or less immobilized as well Venezuela's
roughly 120,000 troops less than half of
the Colombian Army with a reasonable
number of armed vehicles but no aircraft
carriers or destroyers the government
says two million citizens militias have
been armed and trained to protect the
country a number nobody can confirm and
while high-level officials remain loyal
to President Maduro a number of soldiers
as deserted this year
in an actual war scenario what you would
see is probably the Colombian Navy
blockading Venezuelan ports with
probably great effectiveness and then
the question is when would the United
States get involved
yet Maduro insists they are ready to
defend their homeland from an invasion
even a stray latina keen mother fin de
Venezuela has people who defend it with
ideas with words with politics with
diplomacy and with weapons Colombia told
its citizens to remain calm as Venezuela
carries out the military drills along
the border while the United States and
other countries and Wednesday called for
the activation of a regional mutual
defense pact in case of an attack on
Colombia something few believed possible
Allison Iraheta
al Jazeera Bogota